cooking in Zelda breath of the wild is
essential to your survival but there are
quite a few food-related things that the
game doesn't really explain if you're
not sure where to start or what you even
need to cook we've got you covered we
also have more tips including nine
things the game doesn't tell you first
you need to gather some ingredients
there are four main types regular food
food with a bonus effect critters and
insects and monster parts you can climb
trees to get apples pick spicy peppers
off the vine catch Restless crickets in
the grass and kill becau blends to get
their horns just to name a few most
ingredients will have their uses laid
out in their description so if you're
absolutely lost start there there are
generally three types of dishes you can
make basic ones that only fill your
hearts elixirs that just give you a buff
in status dishes that both fill your
hearts and give you a buff combine basic
food items for heart dishes mix monster
parts and critters for elixirs and throw
in a status effect food like spicy
peppers with normal food to get status
dishes
be warned food only goes with other food
and critters go with monster parts
combining them in creative ways will get
you dubious food which will technically
fill some of your hearts but you could
use those ingredients for something
better next find a cooking pot they can
be in town stables and Picabo and camps
and you need to light a flame underneath
them to start cooking they're often near
an open flame so just use a torch to
light it side note you can also start an
emergency fire of your own by dropping
wood and flint and hitting it with a
sword if you can't find a cooking pot
you can drop most food near the fire to
quickly roast it and slightly increase
how many hearts it'll fill it will
literally catch fire but if you keep an
eye on it and pick it up as soon as it's
fully cooked it won't burn to a crisp
Plus roasted items stack in your
inventory unlike cook dishes to use a
cooking pot go into your inventory
select the ingredient you want to use
and choose hold you can hold up to five
ingredients at a time once you have your
ingredients ready stand over the pot and
choose cook to cook
you'll want plenty of health dishes on
hand before you go anywhere you can
combine things like meat fish fruits
veggies mushrooms and a variety of
plants in a pot for something tasty and
nutritious but don't go crazy adding
ingredients if you only have a few
hearts stick to one or two ingredients
if you're at the very beginning and if
you have more hearts to fill at a high
role herb or a few Hylian shrooms to
some raw meat for an easy but more
filling dish for tons of hearts cook
with a hearty ingredient like a hardy
truffle the dish you make will grant you
full recovery and extra hearts for a
time and if you throw in a ferry you'll
get a lot more hearts from whatever you
make together don't worry it won't
actually cook the ferry adding food with
special effects to a basic dish will
make it the Status version of that dish
so you can make a mushroom skewer by
cooking a Hylian shroom and you can make
an energizing mushroom skewer by adding
a stamina filling stem mellow shroom to
that basic dish add more of the effect
ingredient to increase the potency of
the buff and add more of the basic food
to increase the hearts you'll get from
it just don't mix two or more kinds of
effects because they'll just cancel each
other out elixirs are a bit more
complicated there are two factors to
look for the quality of the puff and the
time it lasts buffs can be low mid or
high level and generally correspond to
the kind of critter you use and the buff
timer can usually be extended by adding
more monster parts note that critters
include small animals like frogs as well
as insects but not snails for some
reason sometimes you'll get an extra
special sound effect when cooking and
that means you had a critical success
you'll get a bonus like more hearts or a
better buff at random if you cook during
a Blood Moon you're guaranteed a
critical success so time you're cooking
accordingly finally make sure you have a
good balance of heart dishes status
dishes and elixirs ready for your
adventures since buffs don't stack
eating an elaborate status dish when you
only need to fill your hearts would wipe
whatever status you already have and if
you don't need the buff at all then it's
a total waste of course like most of
breadth of the wild cooking is a lot of
trial and error let us know in the
comments what your favorite recipes are
and subscribe so you don't miss any more
Zelda tips
[Music]
you